okay I think time is up for the next
talk so the next talk titled semi
definite programming strong canvas plan
for content channel capacity and the
speaker will be seen one from university
of technology sydney where I'm from as
well let's awaken the speakers yes x me
sure ok through our talk something about
quantum channel capacities and this is a
joint work with way she and Rio and both
of us are from the q SI at UTS so
firstly so i would like to thank crappy
conference for providing wonderful
tutorials every year and the last year
Emma Harrow gave the tutorial about
conventional theory and asked for
non-trivial upper bound for classical
capacity and drone war trees gave the
tutorial about some definite programs so
after attaining this tutorial adjusting
about let's combine them and I will
study the capacity problems from the
perspective of semi technical program so
as you already in the previous talks you
already know column channels it's just
cptv maps and there are several
equivalent representations once the
Stinger spring representation the whole
process adjusted isometry from Alice to
Bob and the environment and if you trace
out the environment you will pertain the
channel from a superb and you've traced
our Bob we obtain a channel from Alice
to the environment and another use for
representation is the Troy Jankowski
representation it is just applied
identity map and the channel over the
unnormalized maximally entangled state
it this representation is actually very
useful things it allows us to use
positive semi-definite matrix with
linear constraints to represent a
quantum channel and the capacity so with
quantum channels we used to transmit
information classical quantum or private
communiqué information and the capacity
just the maximum rate for asymptotically
error-free data transmission using the
channel many times so we first focus on
the classical communication the
collateral capacity is established by
high-level shuma westmorland serum it
states that the classroom capacity of a
quantum channel it's given by this
regularization of the high-level
information here and however it is
difficult to evaluate this quantity even
for the one short ha level information
page and assures shows that it is a MP
hard optimization problem and also the
worst thing is that this quantity is not
additive it is proved by hustings in
2009 and even for the qubit and plead to
the damping channel the classical
capacity is our know so this classical
capacity actually characterized the a
simple article capability of the channel
to transmit classical information and
the things we always has have a finite
resource and we are still in the early
stage of quantum information processing
we have to consider some practical
question there is given finite uses of
the channel how to efficiently evaluate
or optimize the trade-off between the
communication rate that is the amount of
information we can transmit over the
channel and the error probability flow
of the information processing
we also study need to consider the
assistive capacities that is Alice and
Bob can use auxiliary free resources to
assist communication the motivation of
considers these capacities is that we
can use it actually to increase the
capacities and sometimes it will
simplify the problem one such example is
the income Mesilla capacity when
assisted by entanglement the classical
capacity formula is very beautiful it's
just a single letter optimization
problem and can be efficiently soft this
intimacy quest is given by Burnett Show
Smalling and supplier so based on this
background in this talk we main focal we
are firstly focus on the non-synthetic
communication capability that is the
first thing is given rate what is the
maximum success probability of
transmitting information at this rate
and also given error tolerance how much
information can we transmit over this
channel then we were using some kind of
one-shot results to derived or exploit
asymptotic capability of transmitting
information we will provide non-trivial
upper bounds for classical and quantum
capacities of general column channels
and also use it to study some specific
basic channels and both these results
will be given by semi definite program
and we notice here this SDP is an
electrical truly improve and you can
refer what is put for more details and
or this SDP can be efficiently solved by
interior point algorithms and you can
implement it on your computer combining
the CVX software and the quantum tube
ox cute lab so let us start the one-shot
information theory the information shono
is the father of information theory and
in his famous paper in 1948 he says that
the fundamental problem of communication
is just reproducing at one point either
exactly or approximately a message
selected not at another point there is
Alice and Bob use encoder in the decoder
too and the channel learned to
communicate and they hope they can
transmit messages from one side to
another side approximately and we use
the optimal success probability to
measure this capability that is we
maximize this average success
probability over all the possible
encoders and decoders and we can
transfer this into this some kind of
quantum language and this K is just the
computation basis and then with this
optimal successor would success
probability the classical capacity is
given can be defined in this form
maximize the rate are such that the
communication well has 0 well has no
arrow in the limit of the channel use so
now the clean question is how to solve
or estimate this optimal success
probability and this is the optimization
problem and we note that the main
difficulty women is the channel m the
final channel we obtain is composed by
the encoder the channel another decoder
so one smart idea is to sink this
encoder and decoder as a bipartite of
Russia and since we are doing
communication we hope this
Papa her operation is with no signaling
constraint there is Alice and Bob cannot
use this Bible title preaching to
communicate classical information this
is the so-called non signaling code
eerie word first study of Island mussels
for quantum communication and one first
and winter for their error communication
and it is also known as causal
operations in physics also the classical
version was used to study their aerial
communication and the classical
communication x cubed at all animals and
also we can obtain a hierarchy of coat
by adding constraints on this Bible
hello operation and for example since we
hope to obtain some more tractable
optimization problems so one good
constraint is the pizza called PBT
constraint erika rains first used it to
study distillation problem and eleven
modules use it to study quantum
communication problem now the problem is
just optimize order possible koda pie
which satisfy non signaling constraint
or no signal E&P BTW constraint to make
this optimal success probability as
large as possible and our result is that
the first result is that when a
ceasefire non signaling and ppt can
close the optimal success probability is
given by the semi definite program and
here given channel n JN is just the troy
matrix of this channel and m is the
message or size and we maximize the
trace of J and operator F over these
constraints and where we needed
for the non signal s is a case one just
need to remove this Peabody constraint
to opportunities optimal success
probability so I will give a schedule of
how to prove this theorem so as you can
see our target is to simplify or refine
this optimization problem so we first
try to refine the objective function the
key here is to use the troy matrix of
the channel and we suppose the try
metrics of m is given by here and we
also suppose the matrix v given by the
sum of projection kk and the key here is
this object function is just given by
the trace of the troy matrix of em and
the matrix V this is some kind of
classical analog of the channel fidelity
of quantum communication since this troy
matrix V this matrix V is just the
Detroit matrix of the classical
noiseless channel and then if we this
will help our simplified objective
function we further needed to represent
the Troy matrix of em by the Troy
metrics of Earth and the Troy metrics of
the cold this is based on sex to the
results about transforming quantum
operations by tribal at all and the
first shown by layering the mattress
then combining pushing this this thing's
we can transform the object function by
this linear function and then what we
need to do is further impose the non
signal and pvt constraint and here we
know that this no signal and Peabody
constraint oppose semi definite
constraints of the Troy matrix of the
bipartite operation pie and then you
were obtaining a semi definite program
the final step is notice that this
matrix V is has permutation invariance
so we can use this symmetry to further
simplify the semi definite program and
obtain the SDP in the yard without and
then since this is a general result for
up to channel we use it to show some
examples for example X access the
performance of amplitude damping channel
let us check this example we use these
channels three times and we hope to
transmit one bit of classical
information we can exercise the optimal
success probability here and you can see
when the parameter gamma is smaller than
0.4 it is possible to transmit one bit
perfectly and when the parameter is
larger than 0.8 the error probability
will goes very large then we use it to
consider the trade off that is the one
shot if so no arrow capacities the
maximum rate such that the arrow is
smaller than epsilon we show that we
assist by non signal and PVD codes or
non signal encodes the one shortly
personal arrow capacity is also given by
semi definite program similarly we also
use giant who represent the Troy metrics
of and the whole quantities can be
efficiently calculated by stp and also
you only need to remove the pbt
constraint to obtain the non signal in
case and this quantity can also be used
to study their error community
information necessary for example we
just need to set the epsilon equals to 0
this quantity is non signaling capacity
recovers the one shot in our signal
assisted their capacity England winters
paper and also you can do the same thing
of a nest
BTW case and perhaps it'll hovers to
lead new results in their area
information theory and since this when
we add a distance it also provide
converse for the unassisted case we
compare our one shot external arrow
capacity with other nolan converts
bounce letters let me briefly introduce
them the converse for classical channel
is given by Polanski poor and overdue
via the approach of the metal converts
approach and then one arena generalize
it to secure channel and later modules
and we winner further generalized to the
quantum channels and give to sdp
converts bones & Easy's optimization
problem of hypothesis testing relative
entropy the first wise for the interment
codes and in the second one's for the
unassisted codes and here th is the
hypothesis testing relative entropy and
these two quantities can be transformed
to sdp and also that and share also give
converts for the interment codes but it
is hard to compute and here we show that
the one-shot not signaling and non
signal NP BTW if so narrow capacity can
provide better efficiently computable
converse bonds that is it is always
smaller than or equal to the hypothesis
testing relevant rebound and the in
quality can be strict for some channels
such as amplitude damping channel
so then we we have already obtained the
things we hope to obtain in the one
short case then we use them to study the
asymptotic communication capability so I
will briefly introduce the concept of of
strong covers the converse part of the
HS wo theorem just establish a will
converse which states there cannot be a
error free communication when the rate
XA exceeded the capacity so as you can
see here you feel communicate over the
capacity there will be some error and
the strong converse bond is is something
forbid that trade-off there is when you
communicate over the rate rate as a rate
over this one the error probability well
goes to one in the large limit and limit
and we're so we hope to push in this
drunken respond to a capacity and if the
capacity of a channel is also a strong
converse bound then we say the strong
converse property holds but
unfortunately the strong converse
property for general channels is still
open so our key result here is a strong
convert either SDP strong converse bound
for classical capacity and we note the
previously only Nolan's John converse
bond is the internal system capacity and
here for any in column channel L the
classical capacity is smaller than or
equal to the C beta given by the semi
definite program and if the rate over
this sdp the error probability work goes
to zero when the channel uses increase
and there are many there are several
properties of this strong correspond the
first is we can easily obtain some easy
to computable upper bound for example
here just
based on the train metrics of the
channel and use this relaxed bound we
can easily show for any note noiseless
channel this point is tight which means
we can show the strong converts property
for noiseless channel and also this SDP
strong converts bound is also additive
for different channels so we show the
brief idea here the idea is consider
unused is of the channel we hope to use
single letter formulas to estimate the
success probability so we hope to find
some sub additive upper bounds such that
the end can be put outside of the
formula and here we provide the PS plus
given by the semi definite program it is
sub additive and the larger than the
original success probability since it is
imperative we can use PS plus to the l2
upper bounds the success probability of
all uses of the channel and then we can
show further show if the rate over this
as DP strong converse ball the PS plus
is always strictly smaller than 1 then
consider uses of a channel since we can
put outside of this PS plus this
quantity will goes to 0 when increase
and then there are there are we use this
new bound to study some interesting
channels for example for the amplitude
damping channel applying this point we
can show that the classical capacity is
strictly smaller than this simple
function of the parameter of the
amplitude damping channel and we can we
compare it to the previously personal
upper bound given by brand or ISIL for
desk and young as you can see in this
graph the blue dashed line is the
previously based no upper bound and the
upper bound is this red solid line and
we give an improvement of this upper
bound for classical capacity however we
also jawed lower bond no lower bound for
the amplitude damping channel and
clearly there is still much room between
the upper bound and the lower bound so
question is how to further improve the
lower bound or the upper bound and we
also note for this case the intermol
since the capacity is originally larger
than one bit which means it perhaps a
given here and this means our strong
covers are bound is can be strictly
smaller than the intimacies capacity the
next example application is the strong
converse property for new channels there
are the strong covers probably has
already established for several class of
knowing channels the secure channel the
particular conversion channel the intima
breaking channel has my channel and some
another optical quantum channels and
here we introduce a new class of
channels this is kind of cue to the
channel width to cross operators and we
show that the strong conversed upper
bound is just equal to the capacity
which immediately
established a strong converse property
this channel is actually quite
interesting things in this case it's
intimacies capacity is to bit and it's
also strictly smaller than the quantum
lavas number and this also solved
another open problem in their arrow
information theory that is the intimacy
c0 arrow capacity can be strictly
smaller than the quantum lavas number
and also for this channel we can show
the private capacity is also one bit
that is we are in this case the strong
converse property also holds for the
private capacity and at the same time
the quantum capacities is strictly
smaller than one so with similar idea we
hope to study the quantum capacity the
quantum capacity is given by the
regularization of this coherent
information and as you can see this
converse is also difficult to evaluate
and there are three nolan strong
converse upper bounds the partial
transposition bound given by 11 winner
and the later proved to be a strong
converse by Mueller homes rib and wolf
there are also raise the information
given by two mummies rowdy and winter
and also channels internal cost given by
Berta at all enthusiast sorting so here
we similar idea we derive SDP strong
converse bound for the quantum capacity
is given by this kind of optimization
problem and if the rate is exceeds this
SD PQ gamma the fidelity will go to 0
when only increase and this result is
built on the
optimal fidelity of transmitting quantum
information assist by pbt codes which is
given by layer and modules last year and
the proof is just quite similar to the
SDP strong converts bound for classical
capacity we just show also this one is
tied for the noiseless channel and you
can we can show that this bond is
additive on a tensor product so we
further compare our bond with the nolan
strong converse bond for example for the
partial transposition bound here we used
another alternative expression of
complete bounded trace norm from watches
paper and we can show for any quantum
channel the SDP strong converse bond is
always smaller than or equal to the
partial transposition bound this can be
proved by using SDP techniques for
example we can construct feasible
solutions of this complete bound trace
norm from the stp of this kilogram of Q
gamma and the inequality can be strict
we show example here the channel is
given is given by this cross operator
representation and we can show the solid
line is the SDP strong converse bar and
the blue dashed line is the partial
transposition bone
so too in summary we first show the
non-synthetic classical communication
acid by now signaling and anon signal in
PVD preserving codes we show that in
this when I sit by this kind of codes
most optimal success probability and the
one shorty personal error capacity can
be given by s DPS and with this this
means we can totally estimate the
trade-off under this assistance and then
we can use it to explore the limits of
asymptotic classical or quantum
communication we can provide SDP strong
converse bound for classical capacity
and use it to provide improved upper
bounds for amplitude damping channel and
also show strong converts property for
new class of channels and then we use
similar idea to establish the SDP strong
converse bound for quantum capacity
which improved as a partial
transposition bound and however there
are still many problems unsolved for
example we hope to find the title strong
converse bound without using the Edit
heavy activity technique of semi
definite programming and also for some
for this kernel basic channels the
amplitude damping channel the classical
capacity is still unsolved and there is
due a gap between the lower bound and
upper bound nor so since we use this
kind of s and Peabody codes we hope to
study how to implement this kind of code
and also we do not know the relationship
between the SDP bound and the reins
information by Tom amisha well d and
winter
and finally we hope to generalize this
approach to the to study that continuous
variable quantum channels the details
are given is to archive papers and I
would like to thank my collaborators way
an array yaar and that's all thank you
okay so we have time for a couple
questions maybe a fedex first and then
mark the second so in your stp bound on
the corner capacity if you assume that
the channels degradable does that
simplify somehow and give you something
better yeah listen just a fair question
care so in the in your eyes to be strong
commerce pound on the corner capacity if
you assume that the channel is
degradable does that simplify somehow
and give you something better I mean do
you do you get closer to the career
information for example or yeah yeah
that's a good question and I haven't
deal with some this example this case
and I guess perhaps thank you just to
clarify yeah good your q gamma is that
an upper bound on the two-way assisted
quantum capacity the quantum capacities
yes sorry classical I haven't approved
it is the Tuatha just a while worth a
thief it's just it's just an upper bound
on one way it says yeah talk about wife
so the first question related to what
the Felix was asking if I was about to
ask how how's your bank compared to the
bound that we saw last year by the wit
and his collaborator using approximate
equitable channels because they're bound
is actually very tight and it also
applies to both classical quantum and
private channels but private capacity so
there's no comparison
I am seeing in this talk we first for
you so Debbie asked have you ever
compare Europe and quantum bang with
Darby spawn David last q IP or sure yeah
I compare and I compare it in the for
paper so it's also the same Channel yeah
just for this channel and things i can
compare this ppt ball this sdv bound to
the upper bounds gave by suit her at all
a real approach of approach material
channels and I can show when I is large
larger than for exam their appointed to
this sdp bond is strictly better than
the suit respond yeah I calculated and
for this channel it can be strictly
better what about including channel
tissue the same calculation for the
employ damping channel where your upper
and lower bounds are very far apart and
I want the word the early ballots for
also for the conquest of amplitude
attempt in general the classic capacity
for the epidemic journal you show a plot
where the lower bar and the upper bound
are very far apart oh yeah this picture
okay so this is the lower bound this one
and the blue eyes the a problem
previously best upper bound and the red
line is the new upper bound given by
steepy strong convert spa and it is it
improves but it's still much room
between here but so the question is um
you said that the previous pass upper
bound learn so you already shot that it
is worse than so your ensure that this
blue tata upper bound is better than the
one derived from the approximate
degradable channel from last year
that works for console capacity to write
it works for all three capacities any
other questions okay if not they sank
the speaker again and he would have a
souvenir
[Applause]